bayonetta 3 has been one of the most
anticipated games for nintendo switch
for several years it was announced way
back in 2017 at the game awards and
since then all we've gotten were ports
of the first two games
we finally got to see the game in action
in summer 2021 assuring us that it
wasn't vaporware but still most of the
game's features remained a complete
mystery that is until recently when
bayonetta 3 finally got a release date
and some shiny new info for fans to
feast on here's what we know about
bayonetta 3 so far
in bayonetta 3 the umbra witch teams up
with some familiar faces as well as a
new one named viola in order to put an
end to the terror of the mysterious evil
known as homunculi these new baddies are
considered man-made bio-weapons and
according to viola any hope for
defeating them lies with a scientist
named sigurd as far as who viola is very
little is still known but the release
date trailer does hint at a connection
between the character and luca
but i'm sure we'll have plenty of time
to uncover everything about viola as she
is a playable character that wields a
sword and has a cat companion named
cheshire aside from luca some of those
other familiar faces you can expect to
see include jean roden and enzo and
that's pretty much all we've been given
in terms of plot as developer platinum
games has remained tight-lipped about
many details for years however we can
confirm some of the locations players
will visit in bayonetta 3 which include
tokyo and china as for why the game's
main character is taking out enemies in
the middle of the shibuya district fans
have their theories but we'll have to
wait for the official word from platinum
before diving into all of that now fans
of the bay neta series should be very
familiar with moves like witch time and
torture attack but july's release date
trailer also teased a few new mechanics
that are sure to please one of which is
called the demon masquerade a move that
allows bayonetta to unleash even more
magic power by fusing with an infernal
demon you can only masquerade as this
demon for a short time but it sure does
look powerful the other is called demon
slave in this move lets bayonetta
control demons from a distance for some
welcome to help in battle this feature
is different yet similar to the
summoning of bayonetta 1 and 2. it even
features some familiar demons like
gamora or malthus a major new addition
to the bayonetta series is what platinum
games has named naive angel mode and
according to the company it is a
revolutionary feature that will allow
more people to fully enjoy it while the
mode is off bayonetta will be fully nude
with more sensitive areas of course
covered up by her magic hair whereas
when the mode is on she'll simply be
wearing her full outfit and the mode
does not just affect bayonetta in the
release date reveal trailer we see a
scantily clad butterfly demon also get a
bit more clothing to help make things a
bit less risque on twitter platinumgame
said by turning it on you can play right
in the living room without having to
worry about what's on screen
we think bayonetta 3 is being directed
by yusuke miata who previously served as
a game designer on astral chain despite
that game releasing two years after
bayonetta 3's original announcement in a
blog post explaining his approach to
directing the game miata said he aims to
make bayonetta control exactly how the
player wants her to
creating action connected directly to
the brain it's an important aspect of
the first two titles as well
particularly with how it rewards
perfectly timed dodges hideki kamiya who
directed the original game is the
executive producer on bayonetta 3. he is
still responsible for overseeing the
world and story in the game prior to his
time at platinum games he worked on the
devil may cry series and resident evil
2. when it comes to the voice of
bayonetta it seems fans may have to get
used to someone other than series
veteran helena taylor fans have been
quick to point out the differences with
the voice in the new trailers and many
are hoping this bayonetta is just a
younger version or one from another
universe with helena's making an
appearance at some point in the story
bayonetta 3 will be released on october
28 60 bucks like its predecessor
bayonetta 3 will be published by
nintendo thus making it an exclusive for
the switch
on twitter the original game's director
revealed platinum games wouldn't mind
having the game on other platforms but
that decision is in nintendo's hands the
first bayonetta was a multi-platform
game that originally didn't release on
nintendo's system at all however
bayonetta 2 was a wii u exclusive
because the game would not exist without
nintendo's publishing the first game is
also finally getting a physical release
on switch on september 30th alongside
the release date for part 3. nintendo
has also announced that there will be a
special edition of the game called the
trinity masquerade edition that comes
with a 200 page art book and three
reversible game cases more details will
be announced later according to the
nintendo store page baynetta 3 has been
rated m of course for violence blood and
gore strong language and partial nudity
makes me wonder if this game is
considered a t-game when playing in
naive angel mode though the game will
take up 15 gigs worth of space from your
switch which isn't bad if you think
about it and it supports handheld mode
tabletop mode and tv mode bayonetta 3 is
currently listed as a single player
experience but its predecessor did
feature two-player online and local
co-op so it is possible that a similar
feature could be announced for part 3 as
well bayonetta is walking on familiar
ground but also bringing new additions
like demon masquerade demon slave and
naive angel mode for fans and newcomers
alike there is still a decent amount of
time between now and october 28th so if
you're excited for bayonetta and want
all the latest info on the game make
sure you're subscribed to gamespot
[Music]